there's a pie store ever really checked
out the pie store so we can't really
tell you too much about that and then as
far as like browsing the Internet is
concerned well first of all a one more
thing for the Internet there's also like
kind of like your notepad it's called
like leaf pad or something like that
let's see if I can find its prying
accessories yeah so this is like your
notepad basically where you can poop
something typing on the wrong keyboard
or you can type you know whatever kind
of stuff you want it's been nice pretty
font and then as far as the Internet is
concerned there's this browser here I'm
not sure what it is it's just closed
itself web browser there's also some
other browsers that you've come in here
and like below so you can screw up and
call it dildo everything on then and the
best one I at my opinion of course
Midori I'll give you private browsing
just in case you want to watch porn on
your Raspberry Pi or you can use net
surf mister is pretty fast but it was
like it's a really basic web browser
like it was really hard for me like I
couldn't figure out how to actually make
something download like I would click on
a download link and nothing would happen
so I think like net surf is just like a
really really basic I guess and then
this other browser was actually it we'd
actually download with the other
browsers but no what you want to do I
guess but honestly it you can if you buy
a Raspberry Pi to like view the Internet
shame on you
so we're not really gonna talk about
that too much but if you want like a
cheap computer like play online and type
and stuff just look by the time you're
done getting like a screen a keyboard
and a mouse and speeding up your ass
berry pie like buy one of these a little
easier one netbooks they're awesome so
anyway that's not what we're doing here
then I will be at least talking about
overclocking this thing and to other
stuff in the future tutorials now the
next thing that I just want to teach you
guys real quick is how to shut down your
Raspberry Pi if you don't know how to
shut down your Raspberry Pi chances are
you might you might think about a
knowledgeable plug
don't do it because every single time my
Raspberry Pi plug has been pulled or the
power has been cut off for whatever
reason the SD card has been corrupted so
every time you're not saving yourself
any time by doing that these are my
experience so the way to shutdown
let's see the start those gears anyway
the way it should have found is just
pull up your your terminal here you know
what you're gonna want it tight
it is sudo shutdown - Shh and now and
that's going to shut down your Raspberry
Pi so you'll go ahead and do that and in
a moment it will totally shut itself off
and as you can see we have absolutely no
signal so let's say you're at this point
you're like okay we'll have a turn
Raspberry Pi right back on here and you
see you see it's powered but there's no
other light going and I think I
mentioned it another video but I'm
refilling this one so I'm just gonna
ream engine it again but like on a
computer like a Start button you could
never wire a computer to always be on
has to have a start button where when
you push it it launches or it sends the
signal once because you can't send a
constant signal if you if you're not
familiar with electricity you can think
of it like with your car right you hit
you start your car until it starts but
you want to keep holding the starter
right that's really bad for your car and
your battery but anyway so to get this
to restart you just unplug the power and
Reap plug the power back in and you
should see a green light flash just
momentarily and that's its ending yeah
it went earth that's it just sending the
signal momentarily like a start switch
might do so anyway it's plugged in it's
powering up at the moment you soon will
see some stuff popping up on the monitor
here and sure enough here we go it's
gonna launch some stuff if you wanted to
go back to that old screen you would you
would have held shift we didn't really
do that so I think it'll launch a
straight
or by us because I don't know we didn't
choose to go to the test stop
so wait as it's starting up here I know
it seems like it's a while but never
remember like the old days when you're
older how long it would take to start
your other computer like back in like
2005 I mean this is faster than mine
2005 computer it's got more RAM to
anyway well in that 2005 I guess
probably 2003 anyway best berry pie
login we already kind of talked about
this it's hi Astrid is raspberry I was
thinking type of rash berry it's not
gonna show up if you've ever done like
passwords in any sort of in line they
don't show it usually anyway hit enter
and that should get you all set up and
now we're back at that command line here
and the way to get started or patch I
guess it would be batch here these again
start yes
and that'll send you back to your
desktop or you can just do everything in
the command line and the next awesome
thing that I'll probably be showing you
guys is how to use SSH and get your if
your Raspberry Pi totally headless
because you really don't need it monitor
for really anything except for making
the setup process easier but once you've
done that everything you do in your
Raspberry Pi can really be done via the
terminal or you could install like a
screen sharing application there's a few
of those so I'll be showing you guys
some of those in some other videos as
well but for now that's gonna conclude
this video as always thanks for watching
thanks for your supportive subscriptions
and until next time